Patrick Henry gives a speech I think
that ignites a revolution hey give me
liberty or give me death at the end of
that speech that room according to John
ridpath who I think is a really good
historian is stunned into silence now
this is a room full of intellectuals I
mean I don't know if Thomas Jefferson is
in the room but it's those kinds of guys
and Patrick Henry lays down the gauntlet
and the reason he's doing it is because
of locks idea is a hundred years prior
to that freedom is on the table and they
could taste they could smell it they
knew this is a good thing okay he gives
that speech we have a revolution the
world historically speaking the first
country in history is now established
based on individual rights huge so you
study some philosophy and the right
philosophy and you start to think well
my mind is viable it's you know truck
the volition man where's the switch
there's a real world out there and I can
do something about I can build this
business I can pursue my goals I can be
happy in this life on this earth I'm
going to do that great stories when I
first started this would have been
probably 1985 so i think i had my first
wines made so if ever I had a little
couple of slow days at the winery I'd go
to Southern California try to sell wine
and I was just miserable that first year
because it was tough you know we were a
little bit maybe in a recession sales
were tough tough to find nobody knew who
I was I was just literally knocking on
doors I was in Orange County and then
somebody had made an appointment with me
over in West LA and so I just drove like
a bat out of hell to try to make what I
thought was an appointment in west LA in
santa monica turned out that it was a
guy who was not the wine buyer but i
think he was looking for me just to drop
off samples for the owner and who and I
was kind of reading the situation
thinking the owners never going to see
this
amples this guy's just going to take him
home and so I kind of started to answer
some questions to the guy and it kind of
confirmed the fact that you know he had
no business telling me to come drop off
samples I stormed out of the place
furious it almost ready to quit you know
like this I this is not going to work
and so you know the capitalists in me
though said what what should I do well I
should find the guys competitor somebody
around here is got a brain that's
working somebody around here is going to
listen to what I have to say and and
feel the passion about what I'm doing
what I'm trying to embark upon and I
walked into what was then [ __ ] and crow
liquors there's a guy behind the
register smoking a cigarette doesn't
even notice me coming in it's just like
nursing a cigarette I walk right past
him I go to the back there's this nice
little wine section so I go over the guy
go would it be possible for me to make
an appointment with the wine bar and the
guy goes I'm the wine buyer and I'm
thinking you're not you're not the wine
buyer dude you know he goes where you
from like a Santa Barbara and he goes
where'd sound bar by go out toward
Lompoc he goes all in that cool climate
he goes yeah because i like the acid and
some of the fruit out there I was in
shock this guy isn't wine buyer I tasted
him on four wines and he goes all he
goes I think he said you got a pencil
and I said I didn't I go no he goes
where you're going to need one he hands
me his pencil he goes I'll take three
cases of that two of that and four of
those and if you could bring them on
Wednesday that'd be great I I went out
to my car and started crying I just was
just stunned that one moment he just
kept me going was great you know and and
then the other thing that that studying
philosophy is done for me is to help me
understand the importance of integration
and causality the idea in winemaking is
a pretty serious craft there's a lot
going on so I'm much better now with the
you know this idea that what
I do if I'm pruning today the effect
that it's going to have on the wine two
to three years from now that everything
you do in the sequence you know what you
do here is going to have an effect down
the line so you've got to study down the
line just like you have to study what
you've done prior to this point to
understand why you've even gotten to
this point do you have two buds on the
spur or one from last year or three and
how and then how is that going to
influence the future and what you're
going to do right now integration is a
huge theme in my wine making certain
challenges along the way we planted all
of the vines on their own roots in the
beginning which is a typical for
American viticulture because we have
certain diseases in the soil that are
native of our soils and so it's
difficult sometimes to take European
blooded stocks like Pinot Noir and
cabernet sauvignon those are all
European blooded vines they all probably
originally came from the Mediterranean
somewhere they did not evolve with
resistance to various organisms in the
soil that we have here so you've got to
put American species down as the roots
and then put your Pinot Noir in your
Cabernet on top now if you're 20 years
20 plus years I'm starting to feel like
I really understand the influences of
the Sun and the air and water you know
in the vineyard and there's a couple
years ago I stood at the top of the
property I looked at everything don't
get me wrong I'm very proud of
everything I've done we've made some
good wines here I think we have a good
reputation it's not for lack of effort
the whole thing was screwed up I looked
at all you know the whole thing I just
row after all it's just all wrong all of
it you know and so we've already ripped
it out once maybe twice and it's it's
got to come out again if it's going to
be right you know the thing that's
interesting to me is the idea that
values are not intrinsic okay that is
the amount here's a statue the value of
the statue isn't sort of like somehow
mystically in the atoms you know this
thing its value is you know what I place
on it and what you place on or what
anybody else places on it
and that value value is integrated into
man's greater value of his life or any
in I think a rational ethics I do
believe that it's it's true that a man's
life is an end in itself that you know
right to life I think everybody can kind
of comprehend that right it's your yeah
you got the you know even liberals even
conservatives right to life oh yeah
everybody's got a right to their life
you know my question a lot of times is
well do you think that if you lock
somebody up in a cage like an animal
that that is really that's the life of a
man you know because and why do I say
that because they're so quick to negate
the right to Liberty their corollaries
life liberty property these are
corollaries you don't have one of them
without the other I think if I could
just do one thing that it would really
help I would if I could you know I Dream
of Jeannie the politics I would liberal
I would liberalize distribution shipping
I would make it so that a human being
can ship something to another human
being in the United States of America I
would make it so that a human being at a
winery could ship a bottle of wine to
another human being in 50 states I was
very disappointed by the decision that
the Supreme Court handed down not too
long ago in our industry was saying oh
they're going to liberalize it they're
going to open up the shipping they're
going to tell these states you know you
got to allow for free trade the decision
that was handed down the Supreme Court
basically said you either have to let if
your wineries in state are shipping out
then to be fair you got to let wineries
outside of state ship in but you powers
that be in the various states if you
want to annihilate all trade you can do
that too in the name of fairness so as
long as you tell your wineries they
can't ship out well then you can block
the whole thing and nobody can ship in
now that is such a breach of freedom
what it should be is they shouldn't even
be asking the question it shouldn't even
be an issue in the United States you
want to ship something ship it
I want to ship something to Kentucky or
one of these so-called george i think
you know felony states it's a felony for
Bryan Babcock to ship one of my
customers there a bottle of wine I mean
why what Who am I injuring I don't you
know walk around thinking about Ireland
you know John Galt or Atlas Shrugged
every second of the day and like how can
I make this be you know Galt's Gulch if
you know but if it was Galt's Gulch the
government would but not be permitted to
take one step on the property so it's
yeah who is John Galt who is John Locke
who's Patrick Henry who's Aristotle the
John Galt is the guy in fiction that
Patrick Henry is the guy in real life
that's it gets it in this fighting for
freedom you know and it's going to be
steadfast as not it's not going to let
down and the world needs a few of those
the world needs an atlas to hold up the
globe you know the world needs a John
Galt or a patrick henry just you know to
say this is freedom is a good thing man
needs freedom we got to be free
you